foreign
hey I am jumping in here this is future
John
this is John from the future after this
show has already been recorded
and I have to come back and say this
next call you're about to hear
I missed it
and here's what I missed okay so you're
gonna listen to this call and you're
gonna hear me and you're gonna be
hollered at your phone or your
your speaker in your car or in your
headphones when you're mowing the yard
but however you consume the show
watching YouTube You're gonna be like oh
my gosh huh I know I know I know
here's a couple of things number one I'm
pretty sure
after listing this call
that this man's wife
is a significant challenge it's a
problem okay also
I try my best I'm not always perfect but
I try my best to not bad-mouth
somebody's spouse
when they're not on the phone
that's hard right the third thing is
most of the time when you're dealing
with somebody who's got a spouse and the
spouse is just out to lunch the spouse
is just spending money willy-nilly this
boss is cheating on the spouse is
struggling with addiction whatever
you as the person on the phone the
person who's calling and saying how can
I help my spouse how can I fix this I'm
lonely how do I do these things can't do
anything about the spouse the only
person you can change is you
and so you're going to notice in this
call I don't think I messed this part up
I intentionally focused on this guy what
can you do
why is your wife creating a world that
you don't exist in
I think the reality is she's always had
that life
she's always spent money she's always
run up debt she's always creative
alternative life that she is living that
this guy is funding
but that's not always helpful for me to
just Grenade on somebody
so you're going to hear this call and
you're going to be going what do you
mean it's completely her I'm I'm with
you I'm with you and
I really want those of us the folks who
listen to this show who are struggling
with a spouse struggling with a friend
struggling with a mother-in-law
struggling with whoever
to go back to the one place
where transformation happens and that's
in the mirror
that's with you
asking yourself what are my thoughts
what are my actions what can I control
here
so check out the call be nice in the
YouTube comments be nice
here we go
what's up Tom
hey how you doing John I was doing great
until Jenna started talking about the
Swift shows but I think you're gonna get
us back on track man well I feel I know
you deal with life and death stuff and
heavy marriage Hanging On by a thread
stuff and I feel a little bit silly for
this call but
yeah so here's what's going on I travel
a lot for work about four days every
other week and my wife loves to travel
for fun and this month especially she's
gone a lot and
um I'm not included on those trips it's
girls and it's this and it's that and
I'm feeling a little bit excluded and
the other part of that is when I bring
up
um like hey most of my travel is an hour
or two flight from our house and I say
hey why don't you come out for a night
or you know take Friday off we'll spend
the weekend there or whatever wherever I
am and it's quickly dismissed and it's
like hey I need more time to plan and
this and that and and if she wanted to
do it there would be a plan B like if
one of her friends calls and says hey
let's go here for the weekend you know
she'll find a way to make it work
um and so I'm I'm calling you and thanks
for taking my call because I feel like
I'm getting wound up in my head and I
don't want to be resentful I want her to
enjoy the trips I want her to be I love
her because she loves to live her life
and have fun and there's also a little
bit of a back backstory if you don't
mind when we got married we had a lot of
debt and her debt was travel debt and we
did FPU and we paid it off and we've
been debt-free ever since
um a year and a half ago I was
refinancing our house shortening the
term and lowering the rate and she had
hidden a bunch of debt as well and so we
downloaded to every dollar app and paid
that off ahead of schedule
um did you all deal with the infidelity
uh a little bit so no not really not
really and not really and the other the
other and and we're both men here the
other Traders I I was a single dad my
kids spent every other week and when I
traveled with her mom and I would
constantly get emails from her like hey
check out this Cruise it's on sale or
this or that and I would be trying to
make ends meet and you know and so
there's these little triggers along the
way that when she's like hands on you
know to Hawaii or I'm doing this and
works good money is good she does well I
do well we're working our butts off but
there's all these
things along the way that are just you
know when she said when she says Hey I'm
going here in two weeks with my friends
for three days and I'm getting back from
my trip with an empty house and yeah you
know and there's all these little things
and I feel like I'm getting wound up in
my head and I don't want to
um be that guy who's resentful or treats
her poorly or you know where it's
changing my everyday life and I feel
like I'm turn getting to that point well
you're like your everyday life has been
changed
and I I would be willing to bet
um I don't have a nice car but I'd be
willing to bet it
um
that this is just a symptom of a bigger
issue
because she's created an alternative
life that doesn't include you for
whatever reason
whether you hold her accountable whether
you're not safe whether you always have
some scheme or plan or whether your
rules and your whatever always trumps
she's created a world or you're an
anxious mess
um are you a high strung guy are you
anxious a lot
um I do pretty well with that I'm not
but I will say you know and I know you
travel for work and and I'm raised by a
single mom and not a close family and so
I can be a lonely guy and kind of line
that up as well and so you know coming
home to an empty house after being on
the road and yeah but that that's that's
not the issue the issue here is y'all
are co-managers of your household you
aren't doing this thing together right
right and travels but one thing that you
all do separately
right and we'll do trips together but
it's been a while and that's kind of the
other I know but you're not hearing what
I'm saying dude you don't hear what I'm
saying your marriage is running in
parallel you have two people living
under the same house that are sharing
the same name that have two completely
different lives
right and this travel this her going out
of town with her friends her world that
she has curated that doesn't include you
that's but a symptom
of a marriage it's running on a on two
side-by-side tracks but it's not working
together
right and you can't control why she has
created a world
what you can control is why she has
excluded you from it
right right
and so if I ask you because she's not on
the phone if I ask you why does she
choose to why won't she travel with you
why does she not like traveling with you
I can answer you I can answer this from
my house
my wife doesn't like to travel with me
because I don't care about itineraries
because I just show up whenever I hate
getting to an airport more than an hour
like I like to get to the airport just
in time to get through TSA just to get
through and walk straight onto the plane
while they're boarding for her she wants
to be there seven to ten days before the
flight actually leaves she likes to
spend the night in the airport I'm just
kidding but she likes to be there so
early
and then when we get to wherever we're
going I don't know we'll find a hotel
when we get to the town like that's how
I roll and that makes her un feel unsafe
right and uncared for so that's why she
doesn't like to travel with me why does
your wife exclude you from Joy
yeah I don't know we we went to Kabul in
January you know you know
yeah I don't you know it's hard I I'm
the last couple of vacations that I've
asked her about it have been good
you know but our our sleep schedules
different you know I'm older I don't
like to party like I used to but we
still the last I and I looked at it the
last couple of times we vacationed and
we had a lot of fun I know but you keep
focusing on vacation
yeah
yeah I don't know there is a bigger
issue here man
maybe I you know I don't know maybe
because I watched the pennies
um maybe because I'm jaded because I
travel for work and it's hard to impress
me I don't you know
the question you've got to ask your wife
is and really yourself is beyond travel
you're stuck on this travel thing
um
when it comes to how the house feels
when you get home and she's there
how the house feels when she gets home
and you're there
to how y'all handle conflict to what
y'all like to how you like to honor each
other by
um how the other person likes
entertainment and I'm gonna show up
there your sex and intimacy life I'm
telling you right now something's off
yeah
and you keep focusing on this travel
travel travel I'd be willing to bet if I
talk to her it would have nothing to do
with travel
travel is your way of escaping getting
away
right living the life that she doesn't
feel like she can live at home
right
and it could be that she's a brat and
again I'm not talking I don't talk bad
about your wife but it could be that you
would like to have a budget and you
don't like to spend money y'all don't
have and she's like I'm not gonna live
like that YOLO whatever that could be it
she could be very immature
or you could be so constricting and hard
to live with
that she's had to create an alternative
world when I was an anxious mess
I was always seeing the end of time I
was always dealing with
okay we're gonna move our money here and
this scheme here and then we're gonna do
this and then
I I remember sitting down in my backyard
in West Texas with my wife and I said
you I feel like you've created a world
that I don't live in
and she said I've had to
and those words were one of the impetus
for me to go get go get help
right
because I was I was a nuclear reactor I
was kind I wasn't abusive I didn't cheat
but man I was electrified and that's
just me I don't know what your thing is
you might be the opposite you might be
Eeyore bring the whole house to I don't
know but your wife has created another
planet that you don't live on and she
doesn't want you living on it she'll go
with you on your rocket ship trips to
Cabo cool that's fine right I think she
likes you
yeah but there's something bigger going
on man
right
that's very interesting I haven't looked
at it like that and um yeah that's
interesting I appreciate that so here's
here's if I'm you
here's what I was the way I would start
I would take her out somewhere nice
and I would say hey I want to talk about
us
and I would say I've been asking about
travel and I not she doesn't make you
hurt she doesn't hurt your feelings
you're allowing your feelings to be
heard okay I'm gonna use that language
this is all about me
I've decided to get my feelings hurt
whenever you're gone and when you create
these travel plans without me and when
you don't want to go on my work trips
and but then I started thinking
are there other places in our
relationship where I'm not showing up
where we are running parallel lives
and I want to create a future where I
can help meet your needs and you feel
empowered to help meet my needs and
we're working together on this deal and
it becomes much less about will you do
this thing and go on this trip and why
can't I go it's it's a much richer
experience
I'll tell you this
when my wife is about I mentioned on the
show it's probably four or five months
ago when I was struggling with with my
daughter who had was six at the time and
she turned seven since
um
and between my wife and Dr mate Gabor
mate
really hammered home what if I
concentrated on being likable
not on always being right not on always
lecturing not on always trying to solve
every problem or have my opinion heard
on everything but what if I focused on
being likable being fun being funny
um staying up a little too late
sometimes getting up a little too early
sometimes
like
spraying one of the kids with a hose
when they get home allowing them to
spray me back when when I'm least
expected whatever the thing is
what if I just did the dishes instead of
making it like checklist about it
and I tell you what man my whole house
has changed
the marriage has changed my relationship
with my daughter and my son have changed
everything is different now
because I'm working hard not to be right
not to win not to make sure every T is
crossed and every eye is dotted but
to be likable
to be a joyful person and it's just
ricocheted through my life so sit down
with your wife and talk about the state
of your your marriage let her speak and
don't try to correct her
this isn't something you're going to
solve in one meeting
but ask her
my heart to be around my heart to travel
with
if you had to create another alternative
World alternative universe that I'm not
a part of because I'm tough to be around
start that way let her speak and let her
be open with you it might be a really
hard season coming up but man if you get
to get through this and get to the other
side of it y'all can create something
amazing
we are in Tandem and you're working
together
and then you can take all the vacations
you want man
but you gotta heal from the inside out
on this one